thank you
[Music]
I have you guys ever been driving
through the freeway when there was a
protest and you had to stop and [__] oh
because they blocked the freeway why do
they do that I lose my [__] mind
inside bro well that's never happened
Bart is gonna love this one really why
because Bart likes to bulldoze
protesters I picked this one for bird
okay okay
let's not say a whole lot let's just
show you this oh wait we're getting
arrested good
yeah that's good people gotta go to work
bro
I'm just [__] dead body myself yeah
this guy
this guy's a [__] hero
yo he kicked them
where is this
it sounds Russian Jersey
a Long Island there's actually Monterey
Park he's just dragging their houses yep
oh it sounds French yeah it sounds fresh
it's not French
foreign
[Laughter]
these protesters look so dumb about them
is you're fighting the same [__]
people you're not affecting like the
actual pause that's right you're
fighting your homies like protests that
are so in effect that's like me having
an issue against something I go on the
freeway and then I block Nick's mom from
getting to work I'm really making a
difference but now she knows your issue
Burn yeah your waste awareness about
your issue now her is his mom's late to
work for no [__] but also then my
mom's gonna be like [__] your cause dude
I gotta go to work
the [__] out of here now I hope you guys
all crash protesting for women's rights
yeah she's like no I hate women's rights
if you're gonna block my way to go to
work exactly that's what I would
understand about protest is like why do
you guys become a nuisance to the
working class yeah like these guys got
to go to work where do you hurt them
yeah like go to [__] helicopter
stations and [__] and [__] block the
[__] Ballers and be effective
actually
go yeah stand in front of the PJs
do the minimum wage helicopter dude
like the Hamptons or something it
doesn't look at the Hamptons Occupy Wall
Street was so stupid occupy Walter which
is supposed to be that it's like let's
[__] hit bongo drums when these guys
are in [__] the 70th floor they can't
even hear you at least it did more than
more this late like to
try to make a hot take but they should
probably do more like thinking before
they do these protests
I think what the problem is is these
guys don't know how to effectively fight
so the thing is like let's say the guys
that did GameStop or like the guys that
are like out there and they know how to
attack effectively that work that like
you're hurting people like that you know
you want to make like if you want to
make some noise you hurt them in their
money in their bank account or whatever
instead of standing in [__] blocking
traffic and doing all this [__] that
doesn't matter do you guys remember that
viral video that was going crazy for a
while this guy in New York he was at
like like a Chipotle off brand and he's
like Chipotle no it was like it wasn't
Japan like that it was like it was like
a shirt
it was a Chipotle stair Wars guys the
Star Wars one yeah what about stairs
come on we're focusing on Nick right now
but there was he was talking to the
employees at this restaurant and they
were speaking Spanish and he's like can
you not speak
and they went after that dude and they
went to his [__] like job they got on
fire they had a mariachi band outside of
his [__] place they they got to get
they gotta assemble like that but do
that this version Oh that [__]
um lawyer that had a breakdown right
yeah yeah that was hilarious the way
they attacked him is how they got
attacked they put thought into that they
all assembled together and they need to
do that [__] for whatever cause what
causes this for it's for climate
what they need to do is they need to
super glue their hands and put it on a
[__] painting or something put on
David you know what I mean one of the
things about this article too is like
you know if the police aren't going to
do anything then the citizens are going
to do crazy [__] because they just want
to get to where they're going so the
police's job we were all told when we
pay our taxes is like they're going to
defend blah blah blah they're going to
make sure to advocate for whatever the
[__] for the decent flow of things but
then when people are like I don't have
trust of a decent flow of things because
I'm sitting in traffic and these [__]
people are sitting in vests and you guys
can't power move them we've seen you all
do it in the past like I can't believe
you guys aren't doing anything about
this and that's why citizens get irate
and then dangerous more dangerous things
can happen if this was LA and we did the
same exact thing is that an assault
charge for picking someone up and moving
them from the drivers would probably go
to jail and San Fran definitely yeah
this guy gets rug burners
the dangerous thing would be this guy
drags this guy and it's really cool that
all of them kind of played the passive
route but if one guy were to resist a
little bit it turns into a scrap full of
non-vest verse vest it can turn into a
big like Fiasco real fast but there's
teams though that's good Neil was
[__] doing the freeway protest and
the cops came out and they were just
[__] battering people and then she
got hit too Jessica Biel was doing that
holy [__] yeah really that was she was
she was on a highway Jessica Beals
specifically Jessica had a great glow
from Seventh Heaven I'm just gonna throw
that that's a good deals dude that's
pretty true but also why do you want a
highway Jessica Biel well just good
deals
one of those things like right to
peaceful protest is like I totally
endorse it if you're like on the side of
the road you're picking you're not
disrupting something yeah
um in terms of like a workflow or safety
like when you sit in a street where a
[__] giant machine Vehicles can move
at high speeds yeah and then like
pedestrians who aren't familiar with
your cause or like even Associated
directly with your cause that like is
gonna [__] people up you know what I
mean like that loses like like I said
more support like that this is this is
why I think it's stupid okay
these protests they've been trying to do
since like the 70s right and there's
never been a moment when those have been
effective Rosa Parks that [__] worked
because it was like hey uh black people
they [__] use the bus too why do they
have to pay the same price but they
don't go on we're gonna boycott it makes
sense sit-ins it makes sense it's
violating a law and then you're
protesting against peacefully Pro server
right this [__] does [__] nothing
green your hand to a [__] painting it
never there was never a moment they were
like oh when John Pierre put his [__]
hand on the Mona Lisa everybody just
started using they threw away plastic
straws like there's never anything in
history well this was [__] working
you know they had plus the shows too
my favorite thing about this too is like
these guys that are sitting on the
highway they're probably rationales like
oh cars are probably contributing to
greenhouse gases and all that [__]
you're telling me those [__]
don't use cars at all
you're telling me there's people that
are processing not when people are
looking yeah exactly they're all
Hypocrites too it's like I just I would
assume and I'm probably gonna be wrong
for this anyway but I would assume that
it's just a matter of like making noise
not necessarily about like the way the
how the why but just the fact that it's
useless yeah it's [__] useless uh two
two Play-Dohs Advocate if it like makes
enough noise to the point where it gets
to this JK table where we have only
esteemed news come out of our Channel
you know what I mean it's kind of they
must have done something amazing because
this is JK news hey Mom your cooking
sucks and she goes what do you want to
eat your cookies suck
I'm just making noise
that makes a lot of sense actually
awareness mom you're cooking sucks I'm
telling everyone your cooking sucks like
the whole um veganism thing like when
when friends I have that are vegan will
ask me like oh how come you never wanted
to be vegan it's just like most vegans
who have talked to me about it were so
unpleasant I just don't want to be on
their team they're so unpleasant that I
wanted to start eating a steak in front
of them and it's not that like Niners
fans I can't [__] handle it you guys
suck so much I [__] so sick of you
guys saying the same [__] all the time
oh you a Kaepernick could have been the
best backup and I'm like oh my God shut
the [__] up already Kaepernick sucked
actually he was carried by a [__]
great team great defense it's like when
the facts are on paper and it's just
data it's like yeah I get it but then
like when I see the people representing
that data I don't I don't think I'm that
and I don't think I'm I don't I want to
be like that so I'm just like hey
whatever I'm doing I'm happy with it I
actually am like so like I want to get
into environmentalism but every [__]
time I run into people who are about
nature and environmentalism I just want
to [__] their asses up and I'm like man
I want to be on your team so [__] bad
you don't understand but you're a
[__] [__] face acting like an [__]
yeah or like so you just need [__] I
hate you and then like it's everything
honestly yeah dude I'd probably be a
good [__] Christian if there were
better [__] Christians you know what
I mean like I'd probably join a lot of
groups and activities if these groups
weren't full of [__] faces yeah well
that's like any company right any
successful Corporation will have their
face people and then they'll have their
people that do the operations but you're
not gonna have like the pr person or the
face of the company be the biggest
[__] you have yeah yeah Tom Brady
runs FTX
that's right oh yeah well he's getting
sued now that's a group I want to join
she's like yeah now yeah get into the
ground floor dude you know how much they
got away with what's his name SPF he
[__] cashed out of me or anything he
cashed out a bill his Executives they
cashed out hundreds of Mills the [__]
marketing director cashed out with 55
mil like they all cashed out as a loan
that they took on themselves
wow shocking so they were able to hey
like I'm lending out a private loan to
me right
and the genius thing about it is that
they did it all legally yeah like they
none of this stuff was illegal it's
Shady but it they they're so smart and
how they [__] heisted bro they got
Maxine Waters talking about SPF like
he's a [__] hero on Twitter because
they [__] spent money on all the
journalists you pay for it and you get
it back [__] that's what happens
[Music]
foreign